Trump is going to bring receipts we're
breaking into the capitol smashing
Windows injuring police officers
you why did it take it take three hours
to tell them to go I don't believe it
did oh let me pull it out
so
if you look at on January 5th the day
before I said please support our Capitol
Police at law enforcement they are truly
on the side of our country stay peaceful
stay peaceful this was the day before if
you look January 6th at 2 before 2 30.
I am asking for everyone at the U.S
Capitol to remain peaceful this is right
after as it was happening it's good to
know that Trump is going to have the
facts at his fingertips when you hear
all of these kinds of charges that are
inevitably going to come up throughout
the 2024 campaign